good morning good afternoon and
welcome everyone to today's live
broadcast
biomedical applications of raman
spectroscopy
i'm alexis krause of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by metro usa for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at metrum.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
kristin frano
applications manager at bmw tech and dr
adam hopkins
spectroscopy product manager for
metromusa
for a complete biography on our
presenters please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen christian and
adam
you may now begin your presentations
welcome
thanks alexis um and thanks to those
who are joining in today um so we're
really excited to be
talking about this topic
which alexis like alexa said is
biomedical applications of raman
spectroscopy
so first i'll give a brief introduction
to some of the
basic principles of raman spectroscopy
and then we'll dive a little bit deeper
into discussing
some examples of biomedical applications
that our systems have been used for
recently
and then adam will give us an overview
of
the metro ramen spectroscopy portfolio
so when we talk about photography all
we're really talking about
here is the interaction of some kind of
light with some kind of matter
and in that interaction we learn
some information about our sample of
matter
and we get that in the form of an output
which
in spectroscopy is a graph that we call
a spectrum so you can see that little
picture of the raman spectrum
there so there's the output that we get
and then there's the actual information
that we can interpret
from the output that can help us solve
the problems that
we're trying to answer so from a raman
spectrum
we can get structural information about
our sample
that we can use to do either qualitative
or quantitative analysis
so qualitative analysis is based off of
the band positions
of the spectrum so raman spectroscopy is
a type of
vibrational spectroscopy um in which
we're probing
the vibrational groups
that are present in our sample so we're
looking at the actual chemical bonds
um in our sample so because
each uh each functional group has its
own
um kind of characteristic frequencies
at which it vibrates the raman spectrum
can act as a
molecular fingerprint that we can use to
identify a sample
so in this example you can see
the spectrum of the one butanol
and the four isobutyl acetyl phenone
that's the red spectrum and you can see
that because they're different
molecules they have distinct raman
spectra
that we can use to help identify them
and this is a big advantage because this
allows us to use spectral libraries
to identify either unknown samples or to
verify
the identity of known materials also
shifts in the peak positions in our
raman spectrum can give us
some information about changes that are
happening
in our sample matrix
for a quantitative analysis the
intensity of
our measured peaks that we see
is proportional to the amount of the
analyte that's present in our sample
matrix
so we can use the peak heights that we
see
to directly correlate the concentration
of the analyte that we have in our
sample so we can do
quantitative analysis based on peak
intensities
just a little bit of some historical
background
information so raman spectroscopy is
based off of the
phenomenon of raman scattering which was
first
observed by stevie ramen who's pictured
here
in 1928 so in his experiment he isolated
a violet light and was able to pass it
through a liquid sample
so that liquid sample scattered the
radiation
and he observed two types of light that
was scattered one
that was also violet light and then one
that was scattered green light
and so if you look at our little
electromagnetic
spectrum at the bottom left we can see
that the green light
is at a lower energy than
the violet light and so we have two
types of scattering here
one that's at the same energy as our
incident light and one that's at a
different
energy and it's this uh
different energy scattering that we're
interested here
uh with raman spectroscopy
so this is just a drawing of the uh the
ramen effect
so we have our incident energy that
comes in
and excites the bonds from our molecule
and we see our two types of energy
that's uh scattered here so we see
our elastic scattering which is our
unchanged
scattering which is also called rayleigh
scattering so this is that the same
energy
as the energy of our excitation source
and then we also
have our ramen scattering that occurs so
that's our inelastic
scattering which is scattering that's
happening at a different energy
than the energy of our excitation source
so it's important to note here ramen
is an inherently insensitive analytical
technique so
for a lot of molecules it's difficult
for us
to reach really low limits of detection
with ramen and so it's for this reason
that we need a really strong and stable
light source
that can build up the amount of photons
that are
going into our sample so that we can
build up a strong signal
of raman scattered photons so typically
about one out of every
million incident photons are raman
scattered
so a raman spectrum is plotted with
intensity
on our y-axis and raman shift on our
x-axis so the raman shift is calculated
by taking
the difference between the energy
of our incident light and the energy of
our scattered photons and so we measure
the raman shift in inverse centimeters
or wave numbers
and the the bands that are plotted
represent the vibrational modes of our
molecule so these correspond to
the different functional groups that
make up the molecule so
in this example we have a spectrum of
cyclohexane which is
our purple spectrum and the spectrum of
uh collected from benzene which is kind
of that bright green
spectrum here and looking at the two
structures of those molecules they may
seem
somewhat similar but due to the
differences in their chemical
bonding right we have our aromatic ring
for benzene so we have those
carbon-carbon double bonds
so based on the differences of their
actual chemical bonding
we see very distinct raman spectra
that we can use to do you know some sort
of
qualitative measurements off of so just
a couple of things
that are important to note about raman
spectra
so they are independent of the laser
excitation wavelength
that is used um and so for instance
to the right here we have a spectrum
or a set of spectra collected from
toluene
and so these sector are all collected
with three different
laser excitation wavelengths so 532
785 and 1064 nanometer lasers
but as you can see the peak positions
remain the same
throughout the set of spectra regardless
of what laser
is used so a question that we get asked
really
often is well okay
what laser should i use for my
experiment that's really going to
depend on the type of sample that you're
looking at
as well as some of the
kind of analytical needs of the
experiment as well
in regards to raman intensity
so the raman scattering strength is
proportional to
the energy of the laser that's used so
this means that the higher energy laser
we use the more intense our raman
spectrum
will be which also means that the longer
wavelength that we use
um the lower intensity our spectrum will
be because it's a lower energy
laser so because of that you might think
that we should always use
really high energy lasers so we can get
really good
raman signal all the time but one caveat
here
is that if we do use a
higher energy laser that it's possible
that that could cause
some fluorescence issues for us
um in our raman spectra so fluorescence
is a
competing technique um it's an emission
technique so the molecule
is excited and then emits
photons that are that are
fluorescence and fluorescence is a much
more efficient technique than raman is
and so if we excite the fluorescence in
our molecule
it's possible that that could overwhelm
the raman signal that we're trying
to observe um and then in that case we
won't get any peaks
that we're able to do either qualitative
or quantitative analysis with so
for instance the example that i have is
a ramen spectra collected from sesame
seed oil
using three different laser excitations
sesame seed oil is a really um a very
dark brown
oil and it's because of that that we see
some of the spectra specifically
the ones collected with 532 nanometer
laser
and a 785 nanometer laser in those cases
the spectra are
basically completely overwhelmed by the
fluorescence that's
generated um so we don't really see any
of the raman scattering that we're
interested in
and it's not until we shift using a
longer wavelength like a 1064 nanometer
wavelength
that we're kind of able to avoid that
fluorescence region
and then we're able to observe the raman
scattering from the sample that then we
can do analysis with
so over the past few decades there's
really been
a big push for ramen to enter
the biomedical fields um and the reason
for that is that there's a lot of
biomolecules um that are raman active
so these have functional groups that
have
um they have vibrations in their raman
spectra so we can use them
to do different types of studies
so tissue components like lipids
and proteins and fatty acids and
nucleic acids all have raman signal that
we can use
to study them and so the important
regions
for these materials come down to
kind of four main regions so one is
a our hydrogen stretching region from
about 2500 to
4000 wave numbers this may be important
to study
you know carbon hydrogen stretching in
proteins
triple bonds are found from 2000 to
2500 there's not a lot of really
important triple bonds in
biomedical analysis but that's where
they would
be present double bonds however are very
important
in things like lipids and those would be
found from 1500 to
2000 and then from 600 to 1500 we have
kind of our fingerprint region where we
really get the complex
patterns that we can use
as kind of an identifier for for our
specific molecule that we're looking at
so ramen has a lot of advantages for
biomedical analysis so for example ramen
is a non-destructive technique
and it's very highly selective compared
to
even other spectroscopic techniques like
near-infrared
spectroscopy where the bands you get
tend to be a lot more broader
water is also a very weak
ramen scatter so that's actually really
good because we get very little
interference
when we use water as our solvent so we
can measure aqueous solutions which is
really a big advantage in the
biomedical application also the
portability
and the fiber optics of today's raman
systems
really allow for flexible measurements
in kind of a lot of
non-laboratory settings so you can
actually see
to the right here some of the
examples of the fiber optic setups that
our portable raman has so
i think this is going to be really
important kind of going forward because
the trend
in biomedicine is going more and more
towards
portable analysis and really looking for
simple solutions that can be applied at
what's called the point of need
so this might be either a clinical
setting or an operating room
but this type this idea of portability
is going to be really important
moving forward and although ramen
is an inherently insensitive
technique we can actually use a
variation of
raman spectroscopy called surface
enhanced raman spectroscopy
or sirs and this can increase
the sensitivity of our signal by a
factor of about 10 to the third
to 10 to the seventh depending on
kind of what our experiment looks like
and this allows us to get down
to trace levels of
detection of biomaterials and so we'll
talk a little bit about
sirs in one of our examples
and i do just want to give a few
examples
of areas where our systems have
been used for biomedical analysis
recently so the first example that i'll
talk about
is the classification of cancer tissue
so cancer is the leading cause of death
worldwide
so you can understand you know why it's
been such a growing application
for raman spectroscopy in recent years
so because healthy tissue and cancer
tissue
have kind of their own different
biochemical compositions
we can actually use the differences in
their raman spectra
to distinguish healthy tissue from
cancer tissue
and so there's really a kind of a big
push for portable ramen
to be used in the space because like i
was saying then that means that your
measurements don't have to be done in a
lab they can be made
for example in an operating room and so
having
the portable raman system can kind of
provide a real-time guidance
for a surgeon
so this doesn't necessarily negate the
need for
pathology results but it does help
mitigate
the reliance on those results because
they may take
one to two weeks to come back
and meanwhile the patient is still kind
of in limbo
not necessarily knowing the concrete
results
of their their surgery so
in breast cancer lumpectomies for
example
the surgeon removes the cancerous tissue
and then what's called a margin analysis
is performed on the sample
so i'll share some research from harvey
mudd college
in collaboration with the city of hope
medical center
and the kenohi institute all in
california
where they used portable ramen to
sort of classify the cancer margins and
lumpectomy samples
so here's kind of a drawing which shows
the definitions of positive
and negative cancer margins so
if there is a cancer cells that are
present at the edge
of the tissue sample that would indicate
a positive margin test
so this indicates that it's likely that
there's still cancer tissue that's left
at the site of the
lumpectomy um on the other hand for a
negative test that means that there's no
cancer tissue
at the edge of the sample so it's a
likely indication
that the surgeon was able to remove it
all
and so in their experiment they measured
actually with two types of portable
raman systems
one with a 785 nanometer laser
and one with a 1064 nanometer laser
because they were worried about
fluorescence with the 785 nanometer
system
they also were able to sample using
kind of a variety of setups
as you can see in the pictures that are
shown using the portable
or using the fiber optics setup to
measure in kind of a
variety of ways the top one using a
probe
support stand also using a microscope
and then also using the handheld
fiber optic probe as well
they were able to acquire 50 tissue
samples
and while the pathologists had to
was classifying the samples as either
tissue samples
or sorry normal samples or cancerous
samples their raman spectra were
collected
at the same time
so here we have data sets collected from
two different
laser excitation wavelengths so the top
is the 1064 nanometer
data and the bottom is the 785 nanometer
data
so it's very difficult to detect the
differences here
if you don't know what you're looking
for so especially in the 1064 nanometer
data
because we have a little bit of
fluorescence in the 785 but for the 1064
nanometer data
the healthy tissue spectra looks quite
similar to the
the tumor tissue spectra and so that's
why we have to use
chemometric analysis here to help us
kind of parse out those
very slight differences between the
healthy tissue
and the the cancer tissue
and then at the left here there is
some peak designations for
the functional groups that make up
the components of healthy tissue and the
cancer
tissues so typically in cancer tissue
there's an increase in the contribution
of the signal that's associated with the
nucleic acids so
the dna and the rna
signals are really prominent in the
tumor tissue spectra
and also there's usually a decrease in
the signal
from the fatty acids compared with the
healthy
tissue
then they were able to build a
classification model
out of the data using a principal
component analysis or pca
and linear discriminant analysis or lda
so the pca is used for data reduction
and the lda
is used for the classification so these
are actually
two really popular data treatments that
are used
really commonly in spectroscopy to do
this type
of classification analysis especially on
cancer tissue samples
so this is the on the left is the
75 nanometer pca
data and on the right is the lda
classification result so
for the classification we can see that
10 out of the 10
tissue samples that the pathologists
deemed as healthy tissue samples
were correctly classified as healthy and
that 38 out of the 40
tumor tissue samples that they
classified as
tumors were also predicted by the model
to be tumor samples so out of this
classification model they were able to
get really
accurate and sensitive results
so they proved that they can distinguish
the cancer tissue
from normal tissue they were also
interested
in assessing um the margin analysis
and some of the biopsy samples
so in this case they're interested in
kind of observing
how the signal changes
on a transition from healthy tissue to
cancer tissue that can be found at the
margins
so in the a
microscopy image the one to the left
we can see that there's different axes
that are labeled and so
the one that's labeled 6
all the way down the center to 15
corresponds with the set of raman
spectra on the left
so that also starts from uh
spot six all the way down to slot 15. so
they measured the raman spectra along
this axis
and we can clearly see that as we
kind of measure down that axis that
there's clearly a change
in the ramen spectra that we see here
and this change represents the
transition
from healthy tissue to cancer tissue
and so in this case there's cancer
tissue that's found
at the edge of the sample like as would
be in
spot 15 there that would indicate a
positive margin test
so i also want to just to make clear
that this type of analysis is often done
with other
types of cancer so not just breast
cancer
but often the method of data collection
and data treatments using multivariate
analysis
is very similar and i also wanted to
show
an example of kind of what a setup for
an operating room
might look like so this is from a team
at rohr university in bakum
germany and here they have a portable
ramen system
that's set up on a cart that can be
rolled from
room to room for analysis they also have
a little custom sample holder for the
tissue samples as well so
with the portable raman system you can
place it on a cart
and use the portability of that
to bring it from room to room for
different surgeries
so another area that i wanted to talk
about a little bit
is the use of ramen in
vaccine manufacturing so this is
obviously
a hot topic lately especially this week
so we all know that ramen mean or
vaccine manufacturing
is a very long process so beginning with
a raw material identification to
the end with a final lot release
it can take up to 22 months for
an approved vaccine to be manufactured
and each kind of step along this process
needs to
comply with good manufacturing practices
which means that we need some analytical
tools
that can help identify and verify
the different components of a vaccine
along those various stages of the
process
so these can include raw materials
intermediates as well as the
final vaccine formulation
so for raw materials for vaccines
these can include the active components
but as well as preservatives
adjuvants which are used to
boost the immune response of the vaccine
as well as stabilizers and antibiotics
but all of these materials are raman
active
and we can use their kind of raman
fingerprints
to verify them as raw materials for
vaccine manufacturing so the spectra
that i've shown on the right here are
actually components of
an ic31 adjuvant this is made
up of a klk peptide
and an oligonucleotide odn1a
and so portable and handheld raman here
is really suited to
measure these types of materials
throughout the manufacturing process but
especially
in the raw material identification stage
another important material for vaccine
manufacturing
is cell culture media because it's used
to
grow the microorganisms that go into
the vaccine so it's used to grow them
under
really controlled conditions and the
media provides the nutrients
that they need to grow so
typically cell culture media is
very complex and they're usually
composed of
a mixture of amino acids
vitamins glucose and serums as well
so for raw material identification of
cell culture media
handheld raman is a really useful tool
for this so
i wanted to show some data that my
colleagues
in shanghai actually measured with
a handheld system
so you can see they measured a few serum
samples and also
media samples and they all have very
good raman spectra that we can use to do
raw material verification from them
and also here i would say that a 1064
nanometer laser
may be important to reduce that
fluorescence
that we may see from these types of
samples so
the agar the dextrose agar medium at the
bottom
and the bovine serum albumin at the
bottom
both fluoresce with 785 nanometer
excitation
so 1064 is really the best solution
for the cell culture media
so ramen can also be used in vaccine
characterization
and so this is work that marina
kirkatz's group
at sanofi pasteur in toronto
has done with their portable ramen
system so
they use ramen to characterize a new
tuberculosis
vaccine candidate so tuberculosis
is one of the top 10 causes of death
worldwide
and while there's a vaccine that exists
for it
its efficacy is variable especially in
adults so it's worth it to explore
new options for a tuberculosis vaccine
so for this vaccine candidate it's made
by adsorbing
an antigen protein h4
to the ic31 adjuvant
but during this process though they
think that there may be some structural
changes
to the h4 protein that occur upon
that absorption and these structural
changes are important for them
to understand so they want to study the
structure of the protein
while it's adsorbed to the adjuvant
because obviously if they absorb it and
then desorb it
that structure could then change again
so the h4 protein is made up of the
antigens
ag85b and tb
10.4 so you can see their structures
on the right and they're primarily made
up of
alpha helices and beta sheets
and so they used ramen to measure the
protein while it's adsorbed to the
adjuvant so that's the blue spectrum
on the left hand side and they also
measured
the adjuvant by itself which is the red
spectrum
and they measured just the free h4
protein by itself
and that's the green spectrum
so in the spectrum of the free h4
there's a very weak signal that's
consistent
with beta sheets present at 1670
wave numbers but when that h4
protein gets adsorbed to the adjuvant
which is the blue spectrum
we can see that that 1670 peak
significantly increases compared to the
spectrum
the green spectrum of the free h4
protein
so some of that signal can partially be
attributed to the adjuvant
so the red spectrum but not all of it
some of it can be attributed to
the conformational changes
just of the protein itself upon
absorption
so their results indicate that upon
adsorption to the edge event
the protein undergoes structural changes
that
involve kind of an increase in
the formation of these beta sheets
structurally
they did use some other analytical
techniques
that confirmed these findings but i
think this is a really good example
of using qualitative
changes in a raman data set
to kind of under help us understand the
processes that are happening
happening on a very fundamental level
and then i also wanted to touch briefly
on how ramen has been used for
disease detection specifically with
surface-enhanced raman scattering
so with disease detection the
trend here is to have really fast
simple and accurate measurements at the
point of need
so this could be in both first and third
world
countries um and so this is where
portable and handheld raman will really
be an advantage here
um and so for this example we're going
uh we're using tuberculosis
again which is a disease for which
diagnostic tasks are sometimes
inefficient
due to or insufficient due to
the the processing times associated with
the tests
the costs and the lack of portability
of these tests so again here it's
really worth it to explore new testing
options
so disease detection measurements really
need to have
a high sensitivity
and this is because the biomarkers that
we're usually interested
in to detect the disease are found in
very low concentrations
and really usually very complex matrices
like blood
or tissue and so it's for this reason
that we have to
go to surface enhanced raman
spectroscopy
to do these measurements um so
surface-enhanced ramen or sirs
is a variation of raman spectroscopy
but instead of our normal kind of
sampling setup that we have
on the lower left side of the screen
um instead we absorb our sample
to some sort of metal nano substrate
which is usually fabricated from either
gold or silver
so the enhancement that we see here
results
from the amplification of light
by the excitation of what's known as a
localized surface plasmon resonance or
lspr um and so our lspr
is just a kind of an oscillation
of the valence electrons that make up
our metals so you can kind of see
um that drawing of that on the right
there
and so this enhancement that we get can
be
again on the order from 10 to the third
to 10 to the seventh even greater
um depending on the sur's
there's active material that's used but
this enhancement really allows us to
reach
trace level detection of biomaterials
and so this is a research that's
presented in
collaboration with mark porter's group
from the university
of utah so to detect
tuberculosis biomarkers they came up
with
what's called a thurs sandwich styled
amino acid test
and this will detect and potentially
quantify
the amount of the tuberculosis marker
in human serum and this type of test is
based on
the binding of the antigen to
the antibodies um so
to prepare this test um they first had
to load the capture
antibody so it's the anti antigen
mab the red antibody on the upper
left part of the screen so they had to
load that onto the gold
glass and gold film support
using a coupling agent which is the dsp
and then the second part is they had to
make
what's called an extrinsic an extrinsic
ramen label
or an erl and so for this
they coupled gold nanoparticles
and that's what's going to give us our
sirs enhancement
so they couple the gold nanoparticles to
the
raman reporter molecule which in this
case is ds dsnb
um that's the little green uh the little
green picture that's shown on the lower
uh left-hand
corner um and then added the secondary
antibody to that
as well so the nanoparticle the raman
reporter and the secondary antibody all
make up that extrinsic
raman label
and so once the sample is loaded that
antigen
can be captured or sandwiched
between the capture antibody and the
secondary antibody
if it's present and then the third
measurement
is made and we're able to relate
either the presence of the raman
reporter molecule
um and the amount of it that's present
to either the presence and also the
amount that's present of the antigen
so the idea is that if there's no
antigen present
then the extrinsic raman label won't
bind to
won't be able to bind and so we won't
observe any of the signal from
the reporter label
so this allows for really selective
detection measurements of these type of
antigens
and they used a handheld raman system
specifically
to do these measurements um because this
allows them
kind of the portability that they need
to apply this measurement
at points of need outside of the
laboratory
so the detection levels for the antigen
are very low at nanogram per milliliter
level
and we can also potentially quantify
the amount of the antigen that's present
in a new sample from
a a patient
using this type of analysis so we can
create a calibration curve like the one
shown below here
okay so those are just a few examples of
some of the applications
that our systems have been used for
recently in the biomedical field
so now i will turn it over to adam who
will give us kind of an overview of
the metrum ramen spectroscopy portfolio
thanks kristen
i appreciate it and thank you for that
overview of
all the different uh of some of the
different types of applications and i
i know there are more out there that the
literature is filled with people
deploying raman spectroscopy and
innovative
approaches ultimately
when we talk about spectroscopy the
the reason that we talk about
spectroscopy and
part of the reason that it gets so much
is getting so much attention
is because of the the benefits that
spectroscopy can bring
less in the research and development
phase than in the ultimate
phase of when you actually have an
analysis
a diagnostic built out and that's
because spectroscopy
delivers speed and the technique itself
is versatile and with a little bit of
customization such as with the sirs
work you can see you can really develop
application
specific approaches with spectroscopy
and then of course
spectroscopy can be made compliant
which if you are going to be in the
medical space you you
certainly have compliance issues that
you must overcome
when you have when you're putting out a
tool
for the the point of care
um and and if you
were listening um one of the things
that kristen said was in discussing
the cancer
margin analysis and and that's where
typically right she said it takes about
two or three it would take a couple of
weeks for
the pathologist to move through the
sampling of the of the tumor specimens
and say hey
did you get it all or not and with
spectroscopy you're able to
you could potentially do that much much
faster
either via some some automated imaging
or
some very quick testing there at
the point of care just to make certain
that you've you've gotten everything
uh out and and that is that
is the idea of extending the value of
other laboratory techniques so you can
take
the laboratory technique in this case
say the trained pathologist
and to a large degree automate that
into a spectroscopic chemometric method
and that's going to increase
the precision of the results because it
eliminates the
the judgment call and and decrease the
uh the error potentially associated with
that analysis or or other tests
um at metrom we offer a range of
spectrometers so we have
have handheld spectrometers which were
highlighted with a sirs application
and and these spectrometers are
typically used around the idea
of raw material verification
in the biomedical space but we see
an increasing desire to deploy these
into research because they are very very
simple to use and can be scaled up
into dedicated analyzers
for biomedical applications right away
we also have laboratory spectrometers
which are the perfect flexible tools
for doing these investigative studies
and again you could
you could eventually scale them up
into a device and then we offer a line
of process spectrometers as well so that
if
let's say we're talking about that
vaccine production we can monitor
the vex the the growth of
the of the bacteria or the viruses
whatever it is i guess it's vaccine it's
viruses
we can monitor the the production
process of those materials
just taking a quick look at the
benchtop the laboratory raman
spectrometer family that we offer
through our bmw tech brand which is what
we've highlighted here
there are four different families of
systems if you will
covering different excitation
wavelengths
different laser powers as well as as
ranges and resolutions
and these systems are all lightweight
all all durable and all portable
so that you can take them easily from
the laboratory
where you're doing your r d work and
then move them into
those first rounds of of studies
say in in hospital
and as kristin pointed out the the pro
the advantages of this type of system
are the fiber optic coupling because you
get the flexible
interface options so whether you want to
talk about just
monitoring something in say a cuvette um
whether we need just to increase some
stability
as we're measuring over a sample
because we don't want to hold it by hand
although certainly you can hold by hand
for
for a lot of things uh microscopes
probes uh flow cells so if we are
monitoring what's happening in
say that production environment you can
monitor the the raman signal
in a live face and then customize probes
as well
so that we can go in and talk about
measuring
uh perhaps not with a microscope but
measuring at that
near that micro or near micro scale with
specially designed
optical probes so you can get data from
whatever the biological
sample is that you're interested in and
then from a software perspective
key is we offer a
we offer several different kinds of
software that can be used so whether
you're talking about just
early stage development where you just
need to explore
what's happening in the system and get
raman data so that you can start
manipulating it and crunching it and
seeing is there interest there so
software for development
software for analysis either through
our vision software platform
or through integration with unscrambler
and then operationally you can take
those
what you develop in the analytical
software can then be taken
and deployed in routine operation
for analysis that can be done truly at
point of care with
with minimal training or analysis of
again a
a process that's underway
so to summarize we think we've shown
where a number of our of raman systems
can be used
to produce information
that is relevant for development of
diagnostic tools and even uh
and again monitoring tools and and the
big strength of raman spectroscopy in
this space
is that the spectra are information rich
you saw that with
very narrow bands in kristin slides
and it is free of water interference
unlike ftir and near infrared
spectroscopy
you you're not going to get the
interfering signals from raman which
lets you
let you then go in and look at
the molecules of of interest
particularly and it's relatively small
amounts of sample prep
for this and then of course we can
combine those and that's what you're
seeing in some of the the data
and a lot of the research that's going
on is this combination of spectral data
with clinical data with chemical
understanding of what's happening to
produce
a robust classifier under quantification
method
so with that i thank you for your time
and we'll we're happy to take your
questions
thank you christian and adam for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
and as a reminder any questions that we
are unable to answer today
they will be addressed by the speakers
via the email address that you provided
at the time of registration so let's get
started with our first question
you mentioned ramen spec has no
interference from water
what about interference from biofluids
like blood
or urine
sure um so that's a good question um so
we don't have interference
from water um but other types
of uh solvents or biofluids like the
ones
mentioned um will have some raman signal
from them so
um that's why it's sort of dependent
experimentally if it's just
um the blood or the urine that we're
trying to
detect or compare to something else
then we can use that that signal but if
we're trying to measure
the very small amount of something
that's either in the blood
um or in the urine that's usually where
you know your surface enhanced raman
measurements where you have
a little bit more sample preparation
will come into play
perfect thank you christian for that
clarification so moving on to
question number two would this work for
metabolomics
for example analyzing media samples with
metabolites
produced by cells or bacteria
um yes so uh monitoring of
uh cell growth with ramen is a very
um sort of popular uh biopharmaceutical
process monitoring for uh for raman
spectroscopy
so measuring basically the
different metabolites that are produced
by
the cells as they're
consuming the media and so this is
usually done
building some sort of chemometric model
um for quantitative analysis
um where you have some known
concentrations to build your standards
off of
um and then with the
raman measurement you can do it um
just directly in the vessel so you don't
have to sample
from the uh the vessel itself
and then also that's a a non-destructive
measurement so you're not
altering the um the
actual uh sample itself
wonderful now our next question is there
a limit on the excitation wavelength to
use
in raman spectroscopy
um so for excitation wavelengths
we normally have
a 532 nanometer laser
which is our lowest lowest wavelength
laser
and our highest one is our 1064
nanometer laser so we have 532 785 and
1064
nanometer lasers there are other types
of lasers that we can use to
to do raman spectroscopy
like gas lasers and uv lasers
as well they go down into the uv
but those tend to be a little bit
more
sort of intensive in terms of
experimentally
so for the semiconductor lasers we have
our 532 our 785 and our 1064 which
should cover
most very common applications
wonderful now is there any integration
of the lab raman spectrometers with
metroms potentio stats
yeah if i can can grab that one yes
these laboratory spectrometers can be
integrated
with our potentiostats and
if that's not quite the way you want to
go
we also offer a
line of spectrometers that
are integrated with
our with it with some of our other
electrochemistry products
so we have a full line of
spectroelectrochemistry
perfect thank you so much for that adam
now our next question
what about fluorescent signals in some
other applications
go ahead adam please yeah i was going to
say if uh
i think the question was what about
fluorescence signals and some other
applications
um i i guess their question would be
what is the application
is the fluorescence a signal or is it
interferent
so we're talking about raman
spectroscopy we're often thinking of
fluorescence as an interfering signal
as opposed to an actual
signal that we are interested in getting
but certainly you can use fluorescence
as an orthogonal
detection mechanism
wonderful okay
um we want to thank the audience we've
gotten so many good questions in so
let's let's look for another one
okay here's another one how about
systems which are largely complex like
environmental samples for example soil
is it possible to decouple composition
and
interactions
um sure so yeah for very complex
samples like soil again it's
going to kind of depend um on
what you're looking to measure here a
lot of types
a lot of times in samples like soil
analysis we're looking for more
um elemental information than
molecular information quite often
um and so ramen may or may not be the
the best tool for that i would say that
probably an elemental
technique like libs laser-induced
breakdown spectroscopy
is better for that but certainly there
are in very complex
environmental samples there are
sample preparation uh tools that we can
use to
um to uh
sort of sort out the actual um
analyte that we're looking for so for
instance um
micro are come from a very complex
environmental sample but there's
sampling methods in that type of fields
that can be used to
extract the plastic material
yeah and if i can weigh in on that one
just because i
happen to if i go back to my
undergraduate days
i can remember doing a project on this
and we actually were able to
successfully study
the way uh some humic acids
uh in some soil samples uh out of uh
somewhere in in the western united
states
how they were actually changing as they
were
complexing and exposed to different
saline solutions
they via their ramen shifts we could
actually watch some of the peaks the
fine peaks
shift around a little bit and infer
what kinds of some of the interactions
that were occurring so you can
get in there and see that level
of detail because the spectral
resolution is so
spectral information is so high
perfect thank you so much both christian
and adam for that answer
so it looks like we've got time for
about one more question
now can you excuse me can you use a
laser directed beam
to reflect off of skin and measure the
raman effect
uh yes so this measurement
is definitely possible to
detect especially certain types of
tissue it can also be used to
to measure if there's potentially a
skin cancer tumor the
experimental challenge here is making
sure that
we reach um kind of a
deep enough penetration of the laser
through
potentially that kind of upper thick
layer of
the skin so we actually do have
a system
where it uses a very deep focused
laser spot size that's able to penetrate
deeper into the skin
to not just
get signal from that very top part
but really probe into the kind of
localized
environment beneath that so that's
our st probe with a very large spot size
about four millimeters that's able to
accomplish that
wonderful thank you so much before we go
i would like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank
christian and adam for their time today
and their important research
we would also like to thank lappert and
our sponsor metromusa
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us
and until next time bye-bye everyone